deux toiles modèle de marie jeanne et
booba maintenant vous ment parce qu'en
fait avec demain c'est quoi michel
barrette vous le savez les gens vous
êtes généreux gentil si vous avez
toujours une anecdote depuis que vous
êtes arrivé un peu par les faudrait
qu'il a toujours en processus de
création tout un hôtel où je réveille ma
femme la nuit quand tu as ton nom
puisqu'elle moindrement cas bouge un peu
plus qu'une seconde et moi d'amour quoi
elles font je te raconte des choses
enfin vraiment il est 3h du matin ou ne
s'agit pas de l'oublier si y'a qu'à
jeter à l'eau sans tâche aux femmes où
j'avais mon proche dormirais plus sans
panne ont été déjà réveillé il faut jura
compte après saab alors moi je marano
bananes ont pu alors l'a fait pour que
tu m'a réveillé pour s raconté devant
affaires et ce qu'est ce que je t'ai
compte 11 août quatre ans plus tard
apple pour moi c'est pas la fin je les
subis un monde et je leur raconte series
les voyages content mais s'il y en a un
ou une qui rit pas de se fatiguer
tout a souri puisqu'il poudre c'est
invivable si certains mais j'ai besoin
de ce mois ci vivait seule dans le bois
des animaux son vrai parce que je devrai
excuse-moi écureuils faut je raconte des
choses vous êtes mon cadeau de noël mon
entrevue de noël parce que ça tombe bien
vous avez une nouvelle un nouveau
spectacle mais drôles de noëls 23
décembre sur internet
c'est quoi le concept de concert c'était
que si alors michel barrette si je te
dis noël je pense à quoi ah ben ça me
fait passer ta date au début la quand ma
femme m'a dit noël j'ai fait mon amour
je me demandais par la tête dix minutes
noël
non il y avait là ben ouais mais il ya
peut être aussi un peu il faut juste
avant la messe de minuit avec à mon
arrivée il y avait rappelé bil in sik
dugas oui c'est deux mondes il ya des
gens qui signait il y en a d'autres qui
était né lui s'y arrête là dedans quand
je me suis installé en studio avec luc
senay qui était mon bonbon mon ou
d'histoire et bien sûr les techniciens
caméraman et où j'ai commencé à raconter
noël et sa durée 2h15 sans arrêt bla bla
bla bla il n'y a pas eu de coupe il n'y
a pas eu de on va la pause commerciale
en ont maintenant la bla bla bla le sens
je pense que l'udc se voit le réseau
doit regarder les choses comme une heure
ou 20 il y aurait fait des formules
chocs et ça donne ce que je propose
médecins comme cadeau de noël
michel barrette raconte c'est noël et
les plus drôles tac en rolls abus de la
gamme moutien hausse avec adam g
je ramène à bouaké on l'engin on dise un
peu avant de gagner la salle on oublie
de dire roger pour le spectacle sur le
web mais drôle de noël vous allez
ressuscité et à trembler comment vous
vous sentez de retrouver un vieux de
chaume merci merci c'est surtout l'envié
choonee bleus et les probantes à petit
ouais parce que bon je les jolies tué en
décembre 93 sur scène et gatineau pierre
tombale fini mais à chaque année je
m'ennuie lui d'antan des faillites
je lis tellement joué ya des périodes de
ma vie où j'étais habillé plus souvent
en personnages comme on m'aime j'aurais
pu vivre you se dit maintenant on avait
fait d'exercer un jeu on est allé à
paris pour leur chelios rio à paris puis
je pensais plusieurs jours du matin
jusqu'au soir y est dans la rue de la
tour eiffel de notre damien simon caby
c'est mon cabanon bêta des moyens grands
suis sûr à la tournée c'était et il
faisait partie moi alors doha frère
c'est à la fois de retrouver un vieil
homme mais en même temps d'être ce vieux
comme le font ses six mois
autant de gens justement avec le temps
qui passe
est-ce que vous avez gardé l'accent
jeudi à tremblay le personnage se passer
de leur trouver 3 2 à 3 heures il existe
you la tâche pas bien il ya journal de
quelqu'un qui imite new york
mais josé diaz un contrat de maintenance
et de la saison suivi mon inconscient
flambant neufs pas comment je vois la
louer ses larmes et revenons maintenant
au total mais bâche après celui du
paddle il est comme il existe dans matin
n'arrête pas il ya que ce personnage
occupe une zone des babouins qui a connu
tout le monde aime à dire sans succès
lundi honda alors 3 2 1 rajoutons de
costumes michel barrette n'existe que je
peux donner parce qu'en 2020 vous avez
vendu votre salle de spectacle hôtels
restaurants
vous avez annoncé or je m'oriente dans
la retraite le vont parler de projets
depuis la dernière demie-heure vraiment
michel barrette c'est une blague la
retraite leur nom il n'y aura pas de
retraite avant parce que je me suis vu
changer d'idée j'ai pas changé d'idée me
suis dit moi j'aime les chiffres ronds
t'es ok j'ai honte j'ai donné en
spectacle dans ma vie différent et
j'approche lentement de 40 ans de
carrière à 38 ans je peux pas terminer à
à 38 ans je me suis mis à faire une
dernière tournée je vais retourner
déplacent même bouge pas aller safege 25
ans minimum parce que les gens sont
tellement gentils sinon si saddam est
retourné il faut qu'il revienne au moins
une fauche et chez nous ce qui fait que
quand la peine la pandémie va se
terminer bientôt on espère là je
repartirai pour encore trois en trois
ans et demi à faire ma dernière tournée
qui dépensera les 40 ans de carrière et
qui attend l'équipe qui fera que je
terminerai avec douze spectacles qui
penche à gauche bas de pare chocs la
chambre transporter partout en ville je
crois pas aux quatre étoiles avec
l'énergie que vous déployez en ce moment
la femme ne crois pas non plus et non
seulement à l'ipo mais je pense qu à vue
porte parce qu'ils ont moins de temps
que je suis en tournée par le post a
révélé marc c'est exact a peu dormi part
elle met à mal dans michel barrette
joyeux temps des fêtes 13 ans
madame